so this is Super Bowl commercial yeah
yeah it is big explain to me the whole
premise behind the commercial so the
whole idea is that Genesis is the
youngest luxury car brand in the world
like they're relatively new and they are
you know bringing something fresh to the
game and we want to shake up the whole
old-school luxury idea and we're gonna
have some fun with it so how does this
work because I know you to have a sense
of humor about everything well and we
get to work with Neal Brennan who we
absolutely adore already and we keep
joking about it but Neal comes over for
parties and for you know all the fun
things and I was like Neal I've never
seen you actually work before list of
potential you know I was like he works
and I was so excited he does work in
fact and I don't like to read a lot
before these types of things I don't
like to see a lot and then we had a
phone interview with Neal and we were
just like let's just have fun and yeah
scene by scene and there'll be a lot of
improv right obviously I mean when you
think comedy improv you think John
Legend naturally what is it about Super
Bowl commercials that make them so
special they're the best thing to watch
especially if you're team if you're not
invested in a team heavily which I
really have never been except unless
it's CNN or something it's the best part
of the entire game day I mean we I tell
like I come in I'm like Shh everybody
quiet everybody quiet the commercials
are on you're excited to see who wins
Awards you're exciting to see who took
risks who had fun with it and honestly
like obviously I'm on Twitter so much so
it's it's exciting for me to see the
feedback so live commercial wise always
appreciate their huge I mean these this
is the most community watched thing in
America there's nothing else that we
watched together more than this and so
the commercials are crucial you guys
have a new dog we do hey take it over
your house yeah that's true yeah but
they always do it when they first come
and then after a while they're like
they're like the furniture after a while
but at first you know you got a they're
babies yeah he cried all night last
night
I'm just for a bit but um he's a dream
dog he
just so I've never really had a little
furball before I'm used to Bulldogs
Frenchie's it's a and he's gonna be huge
and he's gonna be our biggest dogs we've
ever had together yeah
John successfully talked to out of the
name kitty which she wanted to call him
kitty yeah I just felt like it wasn't
gonna mesh why didn't she call you John
she did call me John it's not about me
once while she does it and and I think
she knows it
she's not supposed to and she laughs now
I'm excited to see your John and said
dad boys almost like how should I react
I just told her my name is not John to
you
you know properly and she I was taking
her to school this morning and she said
it again and she laughed so she knows
it's a thing she's not supposed to do
but now she's just messing with me when
she gets a laugh she will she's a lot
[Laughter]
she's a lot like this I can imagine it
I'm by the way speaking of you you are
the queen of social media we know that
but I want to add or - - to do something
okay okay all right I'm gonna turn over
a picture and I want you to caption it
okay I'm gonna also give down the
opportunity to capture no no no okay
it's not John spot no it's not John spot
all right how about this one first oh I
don't even I don't recall this which
makes good ecaptions' actually I know I
I remember this this was I think at the
DirecTV yeah yeah we played against each
other we did you beat me on a couple
plays yes maybe that we were y'all won
we won and I was MVP Megan Markel and in
one of you are my team is bartender for
everybody you guys take it seriously
very serious it's a hot one what - but
but hike you all with JLo at the
grandest eveness oh my gosh was at the
time when we all say
Neil Diamond song yeah there is right
there I don't know anyone in this photo
but JLo come on Eileen
all right go Sweet Caroline John Sweet
Caroline Sweet Caroline never mind yes
we can I capture this sweet Caroline
that is Benny yeah what advice oh wow
what are you looking forward to as far
as Jennifer's performance when it comes
to Super Bowl I think it's gonna be so
fun because it's JLo and Shakira
they're both extraordinary performers
great dancers that have a lot of fun
music I think it's gonna be good I
always loved you know when something
crazy happens I remember we left we left
early one day because it's so hard to
get out and then all the lights went off
yes that was in New Orleans at the
Supercuts
it was it was the horrible Baltimore and
San Francisco and Beyonce performed and
we after the performance left because we
were like watch the end I had a hotel
beated traffic and as soon as we left it
was perfect because we didn't miss any
of the game because I don't you don't
know if they're gonna bring you somebody
yeah if you just I mean I can't imagine
the pressure that goes on to being on
that stage but these two are the very
obviously very capable there were a lot
of hips shake baby a lot of hips yeah
where will you watch the commercial and
the Super Bowl at home will you be there
what are we doing I think we'll have a
Super Bowl party at home that's man yeah
yeah we yeah we'll definitely have a
party for it and then everyone's gonna
have to know there's anything change
because you're now doing a commercial
with the sexiest man alive
I'd say his wardrobe might change a bit
he did I think your first time doing
this one naked after getting sexiest man
alive he just wore a suit with no shirt
yeah it was pretty pretty shocking I'm
John back I'm back to normal now
it was pretty cool that he got it and
then I was like wait everyone on the
voice gets it so I think that's why he
signed up for the boys that was a that
was the reason how was that experience
you know I absolutely loved it it's fun
working with the other coaches but
working over dinner and they are truly
they were just so they're so incredible
I'm enjoying how lovely people are good
to be around and we get to do what we
love to do every day which is work on
music work with artists that are
aspiring to be where we are and that's
actually really inspiring seriously
which is it's just so much fun I was so
worried that they would come and we'd
that I didn't have enough ready for them
yes they were so casual and so you just
don't think that people hung out you
whatever you cooked yeah I mean it was
it was yeah it was just so nice just
gossiped forever and yeah it was good by
the way you were now living with judge
Chrissie what is that I love the fact
that she has Chrissy's court it's one of
my favorite things I think it's my
favorite thing she's ever done and I
really when they told me the concept for
the show I was like he sold me on the
con I was like this is I can't think of
a more natural thing for you to do it
was just but I mean it was just so fun I
didn't know that something so quick
could be so like so entertaining I mean
it to do these formats are so short and
I can't believe they could edit it down
and make it better when when they say no
case is too petty like these cases are
the pettiest of petty but it's so fun
watching her be the arbiter between them
oh and I get to sit and wear a robe and
it just it's heaven can you tell me one
secret from the commercial one thing
give me one secret I know that people
are watching here from the commercial
they'll probably be like don't give it
up but you can give it to us are we
debuting the the GBA t SUV the first
Genesis SUV is the first SUV it's just a
concept now that people are seeing like
on the in
it hasn't existed in real life and we're
debuting it I think the biggest shocker
is that we're actually gonna be driving
it so you know people do these
commercials and they don't use they
don't eat what they're eating in the
commercials no no those girls are eating
those Carl's jr. burgers none of those
girls are like we do something we want
it and we love it and we sign up for it
because we love it
so I you're gonna see us cruising around
in this vehicle and I know you're gonna
see us in LA
taking Luna to school promised in a GV
ad
how are you gonna bring young hip and
cool to this luxury way how are we gonna
act yeah
we're just gonna try to be young hip and
cool ourselves we got a great young hip
and cool director and he'll Brennan and
I really think the concept for the
commercial is gonna be great and it's
right up our alley and I think people
have seen us at the award shows kind of
like you know how they can get so stuffy
and then we just bring some lightness
and levity to the moment I think we'll
try to do that with this too
[Music]